DEEP DIVISIONS, BIG BATTLES
BETWEEN DEMOCRATS THREATENING TO
THE REAL THE GOVERNMENT
EXPANSION PLAN.
A PLAN THAT ALL OF TOPIC
DEMOCRATS WOULD PROMISE WOULD
TRANSFORM THE COUNTRY IN
TOTALITY.
AT THIS POINT, NO ONE SEEMS TO
KNOW WHAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN OR
HOW MANY TRILLIONS DEMOCRATS
WILL ULTIMATELY A GREAT WITH
EACH OTHER.
THAT THEY SHOULD SPEND.
>> I PLAN ON MOVING FORWARD IN A
POSITIVE WAY.
LET ME TELL YOU ABOUT
NEGOTIATING.
AT THE END.
THAT IS WHEN YOU HAVE TO WEIGHT
IN.
YOU CANNOT TIRE.
OF YOU CANNOT CONCEDE.
OF THIS IS THE FUN PART.
>> I DON'T FAULT ANY OF THEM.
AND ALL THEY NEED TO DO IS --
ELECT MORE LIBERALS.
>> THAT SENATOR THINGS LOOKING
MORE DEMOCRATS IS HELP YOU GET
SOMETHING DONE.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT SHOULD BE
STATED TO THE PRESIDENT BECAUSE
THIS IS THE PRESIDENT'S AGENDA.
>> I DON'T WANT TO CONSIDER ANY
OTHER OPTIONS.
THE PRESIDENT IS ALSO IN IT TO
WIN IT.
>> AS FOR THE MODERATE SENATORS.
THEY HAVE BECOME PUBLIC ENEMY
NUMBER ONE FOR THAT MANY
DEMOCRATS.
JUST WATCH ALL ACROSS THE
MEDIUM.
>> MANCHIN ANTHONY MATT ARE
EXTENDING INTO PLAY.
THEY ARE THE ENEMIES WRITE NOTES
OF THE DEMOCRACY.
>> ARE PRETTY DON'T THINK IT IS
AN EXTANT THAT ARE THE ONES THAT
LOBBYISTS LOVE ARE IN THE MUCH
SMALLER UNDERFUNDED BILL.
EXPECTED THEY ARE REPUBLICANS.
COME ON.
>> THAT IS YOUR OPINION.
>> JUST LOOK --
>> THE FACT THAT ONE PERSON WHO
IS NOT AFFECTED BY WHAT WILL
COME OUT OF THIS BILL, HE IS NOT
AFFECTED BY IT PERSONALLY.
BUT THE PEOPLE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES ALL ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY ARE.
>> FASCINATING TO WATCH THIS
PLAY OUT.
IT STRIKES ME THAT THERE'S THIS
OVERWHELMING DESIRE FOR A WIN
BECAUSE HAVE HAD A REALLY,
REALLY TOUGH MONTH.
BETWEEN AFGHANISTAN AND
INFLATION AND ALL OF THE
FAILURES THAT THEY HAVE SEEN.
EVERY TIME SOMEONE SAYS THAT,
I'M LIKE, DOES IT REALLY COST
THREE THAT HAVE TRULY DOLLARS TO
PUT SOMETHING IN THE WIN COLUMN?
>> THEY ARE NOT HAPPY WITH
1 TRILLION PLUS WIN ON
INFRASTRUCTURE, BIPARTISAN
PACKAGE OUT OF THE SENATE.
A WIN PART OF THE FAR LEFT COULD
BE, YOUR POINT, A LOSS FOR JOE
BIDEN.
I WANT TO GET BACK TO THE "STAR
WARS" CANTINA MONTAGE.
THE HECK FEST.
THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY ARE
TALKING ABOUT.
THEY ARE FOR THIS NEW AGE MOTOR
PLAN SIMPLY BECAUSE THE
REPUBLICANS ARE AGAINST IT.
THEY DON'T HAVE ANY IDEA OF THE
IMPACT ON THE FUTURE OF UNITED
STATES.
THEY HAVE NO GRASP OF WHAT
DISTANT IT.
CHRIS HAYNES HAD THIS
EMBARRASSING ALL CAPS ON TWITTER
THAT GOT FACT CHECKED WITH
ACTUAL FIGURES.
BUT IT GOES TO KIND OF EXTREMELY
HARMFUL AND DISSES ON THE RIGHT,
TOO, VIEW, WIDELY ACCEPTED VIEW
THAT IF YOU ARE ELECTED TO
OFFICE, IF YOU ARE A SENATOR
ELECTED WORK IN CONGRESSMEN
ELECTED BY YOUR DISTRICT IN YOUR
STATEMENT YOU ARE FULLY ACCESS
TO TO IGNORE YOUR CONSTITUENTS,
IGNORING YOUR CONSCIENCE
CONSCIENCE, AND JUST ALONG THE
PARTY LINES.
DON LEMON, THE MEN WHO CRIED
LAUGHING WHEN THAT REQUEST WAS
TALKING ABOUT THE BOOMER WHO
PRESSED IT FOR TRUMP HE DOES NOT
GIVE A FLYING DAMN OF THAT
PEOPLE.
IT GOES TO -- THE PEOPLE THINK
IT GOES TO CRAVEN PARAGRAPH THAT
THE DEMOCRATS ARE DESPERATE TO
CLING TO THIS CONTROL.
LOOK AT CHUCK SCHUMER.
THIS PLAN, THE THREE AND A HALF
TRILLION WOULD HURT THE ECONOMY
OF NEW YORK AND HURT HIS -- THE
CONSTITUENTS WHO VOTED FOR HIM.
HE IS MORE WORRIED ABOUT OAK A
CURE COURIERS -- A PONZO
PROTEST.
DIDN'T HAVE TO BEST INTEREST.
AND THEY HAVE NO IDEA WHAT IS IN
THESE PLANS.
>> I WANT TO PLAY THIS
SOUNDBITE.
IT WAS LIKE HE WAS TALKING FROM
ANOTHER PLANET AND A LOT OF
PEOPLE, I THINK IT MADE A LOT OF
SENSE BUT HE IS TALKING ABOUT
WHO HE IS WHO HE HAS ALWAYS
BEEN, AND WHAT HE BELIEVES IN AS
AN AMERICAN SENATOR.
WATCH THIS.
>> I CANNOT ACCEPT OUR ECONOMY
OR BASICALLY OUR SOCIETY MOVING
TOWARDS AN ENTITLEMENT
MENTALITY.
THAT YOU ARE ENTITLED, OKAY?
I'M MORE OF A REWARDING.
BECAUSE I CAN HELP THOSE WHO CAN
HELP THEMSELVES DO SO.
>> SENATORS FROM ACROSS THE
AISLE TO COME TO THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY ANY DAY YOU WANT.
HERE'S WHAT HAPPENED.
BIDEN IS IN PUBLIC AND BERNIE
SANDERS IS CRAZY.
OF YOU HAVE CRAZY AND UNPOPULAR
GET TOGETHER AND THEY ARE TRYING
TO NEW GO THROUGH EIGHT DEPINA
EIGHT -- A 50/50 SENATE.
JOE BIDEN, S YOU READ IT, JOE
BIDEN DID NOT RUN ON THIS.
I CAN'T EVEN -- YOU KNOW WHO
COULD PROBABLY PICK IT UP.
EVEN DAN BONGINO CAN'T.
SO IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT IS IN IT,
THIS IS WHAT KEPT BILLIONS THE
FACT AOC'S GREEN ARMY, FEELINGS
TO PREDILECTIONS AND TO BUY
BOOKS.
BILLIONS OF FREEBIES, YOU KNOW?
FREE BABYSITTERS, FREE LUNCHES.
THREE BE SUBJECT -- IT IS LIKE A
MARKET FOR WELFARE.
SO WHAT ARE WE HERE?
MARTHA?
BECAUSE GEORGIA VOTERS DID NOT
SHOW UP.
AND WE HEADED DEMOCRATS THE
SENATE.
THAT IS WHAT WE ARE IN
DISPOSITION.
BUT THE GREAT PEOPLE OF WEST
VIRGINIA SENT JOE MANCHIN TO
WASHINGTON AND JOE MANCHIN
PHYSICALLY WENT UP THERE WITH A
SWORD AND SLICED THIS SOCIALIST
MONSTROSITY IN HALF.
HE SAYS, NO, NO, NO,
1.5 TRILLION, STILL WICKEDLY
EXPENSIVE.
BUT WE ARE NOT GOING TO GIVE
PEOPLE FREE STUFF IF THEY DON'T
ACTUALLY NEED IT.
NOW DISSES JOE.
IT LOOKS LIKE MANCHIN IS
DERAILING THIS CRAZY TRAIN,
THANK GOD.
THEY MAY GET SOMETHING PASSED.
BUT IT IS NOT THAT TYPE OF MONEY
THAT WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THAT
3.5.
IT IS GOING TO BE LESS AND THANK
YOU, PEOPLE OF WEST VIRGINIA AND
JOE MANCHIN IS WELCOME ACROSS
THE AISLE ANY TIME.
>> I THINK THE IDEA IS SORT OF
LIKE NOT IN FASHION.
AND IT IS A BASIC COMMON SENSE
IDEAL.
YOU KNOW?
JOE MANCHIN SAYS, WE SHOULD GIVE
THINGS TO PEOPLE WHO MAYBE NEED
A LITTLE HELP.
BUT THIS -- YOU GUYS HAVE TO PAY
FOR EVERYONE ELSE'S CHILDCARE.
AND YOU HAVE TO PAY FOR EVERYONE
ELSE'S ABILITY TO STAY HOME
FOR 12 WEEKS A YEAR.
AND I THOUSAND DOLLARS A WEEK.
YOU KNOW, COMPANIES CANNOT
AFFORD TO DO THAT KIND OF PLAN
FOR.
SO I MEAN, DO YOU THINK THIS WAS
A FOLLY?
IS THIS A BAD WAY TO GO DOWN THE
ROAD?
DOES THIS MAKE SENSE?
>> IT LOOKS LIKE HOW AND
PARTIALLY IT ALWAYS LOOKS BEFORE
BEGET TO THE FINISH LINE AND
NANCY PELOSI ON THE PHONE DURING
THE BASEBALL GAME THAT SHE CAME
TO PLAY AND SHE USUALLY WINS.
AND SHE IS GOING TO FIGURE
SOMETHING OUT.
>> MEANS TESTING.
>> IN SOME INSTANCES FROM THE
SURE I THINK THAT THERE ARE
CERTAIN THINGS LIKE WITH COVID
REQUIRED TO THINK THAT PEOPLE
WHEN YOU HAVE INITIAL EMERGENCY
LIKE THAT, WHO EARNED UNDER X
AMOUNT, EVERYONE SHOULD GET IT,
IRRESPECTIVE OF WHAT THEY HAVE.
IS IT A RESPECTIVE OR
RESPECTIVE?
I ALWAYS GET THAT WENT WRONG.
OF WHAT THEY HAVE A DOUBLE BANK
ACCOUNT.
BUT JOE MANCHIN AND CHRISTIAN
SEMINAR -- CHRISTIAN SINEMA DO
IT REGULARLY.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN THERE
FOR A REALLY IMPORTANT BILL.
AND DURING THE OBAMA YEARS.
IN TERMS OF WEST VIRGINIA VOTERS
AND THE ARIZONA VOTERS, YOU
KNOW, WE DID NOT APPLICABLE
SEATS AND THINGS THAT WE THOUGHT
WE COULD WIN.
WE GOT SUSAN COLLINS WAS GOING
TO LOSE.
WE DO NOT WIN THAT SEE.
JOE MANCHIN HAS PERFORMED AN
INCREDIBLE FEAT THAT HE WINS BY
A LOT IN WEST VIRGINIA.
I DO BELIEVE THERE IS ANY OTHER
DEMOCRAT THAT COULD WIN THAT
SEE.
AND SELF IF YOU HAVE TO COME
DON'T OF THAT TO MEET HIM IN THE
MIDDLE OF WHERE HE IS AND HE HAS
BEEN SAYING TO STUFF IT MUST
THAT HE IS GOING TO END UP AT
1.5 TRILLION, THAT IS WHAT YOU
DO SEE.
THERE'S STILL A LOT OF GOOD
STUFF IN THERE.
>> YEAH, I DON'T KNOW.
I THINK IT IS ALSO A PLACE LIKE
NORTH CAROLINA, VIRGINIA, TEXAS,
WHERE PEOPLE ARE STARTING TO
PULL AWAY FROM THESE IDEAS.
AND THE SUPPORT OF THESE IDEAS
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THEIR SUPPORT
FOR PRESIDENT BIDEN.
>> I DISAGREE.
SHOCKER.
THERE'S NO GOOD STUFF IN THERE.
THIS IS A FOREST FIRE OF -- YOU
MIGHT AS WELL FLESHED YOUR MONEY
DOWN THE TOILET BEFORE THE
GOVERNMENT GETS IT.
BECAUSE IT WILL ACTUALLY BE
BETTER SPENT.
WHATEVER THE GOVERNMENT SPENDS
MONEY ON, IT DESTROYS IT.
YOU HAVE $3.2 TRILLION SPENDING
BILL.
TO THINK WE WOULD ASK THE BASIC
QUESTION.
WHAT ARE WE BUYING?
WE ARE BUYING GOVERNMENT.
THIS GOVERNMENT -- THIS
GOVERNMENT DID NOT SUCK?
NO, IT DOES SUCK.
THINK ABOUT IT.
WE SPENT A FORTUNE ON WHAT?
EDUCATION.
YET LIBERALS COMPLAINED ABOUT
IT.
AND WHAT ELSE THIS GOVERNMENT
HAVE?
OUTSIDE OF EDUCATION?
HEALTHCARE.
DP ABOUT 40 TO 40 PROJECT -- 25%
OF EVERY DOLLAR PER PUBLIC BUT
THEY NEVER HAVE THE BIG
ARGUMENT.
THEY ARE LIKE, LET ME SCRATCH MY
HEAD.
I THINK BIG GOVERNMENT IS A GOOD
IDEA.
AND YET WE WANT BIG ARE GOING TO
FIX THE BIGGER GOVERNMENT THAT
REALLY SUCKED BEFORE.
THIS IS KIND OF A DUMP 90 UP
REPUBLICAN BABY THE PRIVATE
SECTOR CAN DO THIS BETTER.
THIS IS THE LARGEST TRANSFER.
FROM POOR PEOPLE AND WEALTHY
PEOPLE TO THE UPPER
MIDDLE-CLASS.
IT COULD BE A MASSACHUSETTS
FAMILY AND YOU CAN TELL YOURSELF
TO ABOUT 20,000 AND GOVERNMENT
BENEFITS.
PERFECT PLEASE EXPLAIN TO ME IN
WHAT UNIVERSE THAT IS A GOOD
THING TO DO POKE MEANS TESTING.
>> IT IS LIKE THAT IN THE UNITED
KINGDOM OR FRANCE WERE LOTS OF
PLACES.
LOOK AT HOW AND STIMULATED THEIR
ECONOMIES ARE AND HOW MUCH THEY
HAVE DECLINED FOR DECADES.
>> WE HAVE 74 MILLION BABY
BOOMERS RETIRING.
>> Reporter: $100 TRILLION
HOLD